connaissez-vous l'histoire de la
princesse
Issa
dans la légende on l'appelait la
rédemption
on affirmait que cet enfant allait
mettre fin à la folie guerrière
qu'elle allait inaugurer une nouvelle
ère de paix et de compassion
on m'a doté de souvenirs d'un monde que
je ne verrai jamais
d'une loyauté à un roi que je ne peux
servir
et d'un amour pour une enfant
ce que je n'ai pas pu sauver
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent à ton avis
je l'ai trouvé
je suis une enfant de
baguette on a appris que l'amour était
une faiblesse
il ne faut pas confondre justice et
vengeance
au bravades ne restons pas en puni
[Applaudissements]
une petite minute
j'adore ce moment accro
-toi je ne veux pas d'histoire
nous ne sommes pas venus pour ça
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
nous connaissons tous les deux la peur
montrant l'heure que nous n'avons peur
de rien
monteront leur que ce qui nous unit ne
se réduit pas à nos chaînes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le roi est un homme un homme peut
échouer
mais un mythe est indestructible
[Musique]
l'heure est venue
vous êtes cher
protégez votre prochain et soyez
impitoyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lequel d'entre vous est prêt à mourir
pour nos convictions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]